he used to complain about his wig all
the time we love the show but some
scenes well let's just say we don't want
to risk watching them with our parents
those very scenes were also some of the
ones the actors hated shooting the most
The House of the Dragon actors loved the
show but these scenes well it wasn't
always good vibes there's no one you're
just kind of alone in the air
just like bumping about number one
things got weird we're not so surprised
that this was not a cast favorite
filming day while the action between
Millie Alcock and Matt Smith was intense
it had all been well rehearsed and
planned so the actors were okay with it
but the environment not so much this
action taking place inside the brothel
full of other people well Millie was a
bit shook explaining Claire Kilner our
director made sure that we hadn't seen
any of the Bravo stuff until we were
shooting it makes sense why she called
The Experience quite shocking number two
it wasn't a pleasant bubble bath a scene
with a bath sounds like it could be nice
but when the dynamic involves a weird
relationship it's not quite the same for
Emily Carey the nerve set in as soon as
she was reading the script discovering
she'd need to bathe her much older
co-star she had help on set with an
intimacy coordinator and plenty of time
to rehearse and get used to it so the
filming experience was manageable but
considering she was just 17 when she
started the process well she barely had
her reservations it was so intense but
um I think it's so worth it like it pays
off number three you'd think dragons
would be all action and excitement I
just didn't know what to do with my face
working with and riding dragons were
surprisingly some of the cast's least
favorite sequences to shoot incredibly
mundane honestly Millie Alcock didn't
have rave reviews to share it was my
favorite thing that I did on set for
Matt Smith the novelty wore off real
quick there's a guy with a remote
control he's like moving you around and
then they fire wind and rain and then
after 10 hours you like get me the plane
environment wasn't much of a selling
point either it's just you in a volume
stage for like three days number four
the set wasn't always familiar what we
see on screen are Grand structures and
stunning Landscapes but the reality on
set was very underwhelming what the
actors were seeing was a bunch of LED D
screens which Matt Smith grew quite a
deep hatred for but in his defense he
said it was the same for all the actors
number five remember the final scene of
episode one I was so scared I was so
novice the first episode's final scene
was the first one the Millie Alcock
actually filmed for the show that was my
first day and I was absolutely terrified
it was super intense and while she got
through it well it was a bit too intense
for her liking maybe she wouldn't have
hated the scene so much if it wasn't her
very first experience on the house of
the Dragon set it was really nervous
like this terrible day yeah number six
from bad to worse Millie Alcock had a
tough first day but then day two came
along it happened to be the first day
for Emily Carrie on set and for her it
was a pretty solid one the scene wound
up being cut but it was intensely
emotional and allowed her to move
through the first day nerves pretty well
but on the opposite end of that was the
not so lucky Milly Alcock that was my
worst night math like my second day that
was my second day considering the
intense scene she filmed her first day
we can understand her wanting some Chill
Vibes for a minute reason when he was
just like walking walking a walking day
would be great yeah number seven age
gaps are pretty typical here Emily Carey
had some personal history that made
portraying her relationship with viserys
tough she even said it was difficult at
times I'll be honest Carrie didn't have
experience with this kind of romantic
relationship in her own life to draw
from and especially not with an older
man getting intimate for the first time
in front of a cast and crew and cameras
recording it for millions of viewers to
see well we'd probably hate the
experience too number eight we weren't
the only ones squirming would you
believe us if we said that the graphics
C-section scene early on in the house of
the Dragon series was even worse than
what we saw I thought it was I mean it
was hard enough to shoot on the day
Patty considine who plays King viserys
had a brutal time on set for that scene
explaining that it was a lot more brutal
and a lot more emotional than it ends up
in the final episode he was even nervous
that the scene would be too much for the
show saying I wasn't sure about that
when I first saw it number nine if only
he could skip scenes anyone who saw Game
of Thrones knows just how graphic it can
be and how many intimate scenes make it
to the screen House of the Dragon isn't
much different and Matt Smith wasn't the
biggest fan it doesn't help that he is
in most of the explicit scenes in the
first season Smith put it best
explaining do I love that scene I don't
know I have a question mark against it
but that's the world we're representing
sometimes you gotta do what you gotta do
for a job even if you don't love it
number 10. with dragon flying comes wind
and On The House of the Dragon set wind
came in the very convenient form of a
leaf blower literally the actors were
sitting on their bucking bronco dragons
while a bunch of crew people on set
pointed leaf blowers at them when was
the dragons the dragons May
ly Alcock was at a bit of a loss number
11. armor is serious business I had Alma
if you're not used to wearing armor it's
a pretty brutal experience on that note
we think it's probably always a brutal
experience and Fabian Frankel wasn't
quiet about his hatred for it pretty
much everyone on set knew every time I'd
look and we go
[Music]
the actor unfortunately didn't get very
much if any sympathy from his castmates
which made it all that much worse he
would like laugh at me right every like
uncontrollably a laugh in my face number
12. with fight scenes [ __ ] injuries Matt
Smith didn't know what hit him literally
the actor was filming one of his action
sequences specifically a stunt that left
him with a serious disc injury in his
neck Smith powered through the scene but
he wasn't feeling so hot it was only
after the fact that he'd confessed it's
a pain in the neck literally physically
and metaphorically no one digs a scene
that ends in injury number 13. we gotta
talk about the corsets to say Millie
Alcock hated wearing a corset under the
rest of her costume would be an
understatement it wasn't comfortable to
shoot scenes with it on but there was an
unexpected perk that came along with
wearing one Alcock explained they affect
your breathing because they're so
restricting so that in turn affects how
you speak and sound and the way it
affected her well it worked out pretty
well for the type of language she was
using and the way she had to carry
herself as the character it's rough but
it works number 14 mean first days are
tough no one knew this better than
Fabienne whose first day on The House of
the Dragon set left him bitterly nervous
unfortunately the nerves did end up
affecting his performance Frankel had
essentially one job to just roll his
eyes but the actor confessed I swear to
God I literally forgot to act I couldn't
do it for real he just couldn't manage
the eye roll it went from bad to worse
he got called out by the showrunner
Miguel sapochnik he got straight to the
point asking Fabienne what's up what's
going on with your face no surprise the
actor describes the experience as the
worst experience of my life number 15
these co-stars were sticking together
working together on set can create some
incredibly strong bonds and while Millie
Alcock and Emily Carey loved getting to
work together the content of their
scenes left them feeling off at times
Alcock did not like filming certain
scenes together explaining I adore him
and I feel very protective of her and
like her big sister at least they had
each other to get through the tougher
days on set well that's that's what I
think I like you to be honest
considering the content of this show
we're not surprised there were so many
scenes the actors weren't fans of
filming which scene would you have hated
shooting the most drop us a note in the
comments we'll see you next time at the
things